[Applause]
y'all all know him as one of the
funniest people in hollywood
he has done knocked up the 40 year old
virgin and super bad
but he's also a crazy good talented
producer and writer his new book is a
very funny collection of short stories
very funny
it's called yearbook and it's out right
now you gotta check it out give it up
for seth rogen
hello how are you hi how's it going
um it's going all right but before we
get to anything
i have some i have something to tell you
judd apatow told me um that and i want
to know if it's true
he told me that it's your fault that
people scream my name
everywhere i go ah kelly clarkson
everywhere i go
i could literally do anything and it
doesn't matter how many hits
what i do in life i could save a family
from drowning
fires i could do anything and literally
the one thing people
know me from is ah kelly clarkson
yeah so is this true
well i'm i'm terribly sorry first of all
i know you uh
i owe you an apology no it's awesome
[Laughter]
it is true yes that is true it was um
i was a co-producer on on the
four-year-old version i was also in it
but
um it was uh i was a writer mostly by
trade at the time
um so i was hired to write also like uh
jokes we call them alt jokes or
alternate jokes
um and we knew corel was gonna be waxed
and he wouldn't be able to think clearly
probably so we wanted to just
be able to feed him things to say and
we don't always like to only have
profanity so
uh judd was like you should write a list
of jokes
that are like uh dirty jokes like and
and a list of clean jokes
um and it was hard to write the clean
jokes um
and i honestly
think i was sitting on my couch writing
the jokes and you
came on television and i saw you
and it was kelly clarkson and in comedy
there's a thing with like
sounds like they say like comedy k like
like a k sound is is known for being
funny in in in the comedy world
and so i saw your name and it was kelly
clarkson and there it was and there's
an actual i'm in between burger panties
and throbbing monkey tails
i like it how much of that this just has
to be completely blurred out
you see i stuck to the assignment though
really of doing what half of queen
johnson would have
dirty
i am just saying i loved it so much i
did actually i literally was coming into
a theater how i first
heard it was in a preview i was coming
into a theater to watch a different
movie
and i was with friends we were late
because you know i got to hit up
concessions for some popcorn m
m's and so we came in a little late and
we were like coming in and i was like
and everybody was like and i thought
somebody in the theater yelled my name i
didn't know what just happened because i
was like what
and that's how i found out they were
like they yelled your name in that
trailer and i was like why
and then i was like anyway and it's
literally i can be
i can be in japan it doesn't matter
where the hell i am stuff people
since you've been gone never heard of it
but kelly clarkson's name being yelled
during a waxing
that's what they know it's amazing but i
but
speaking of skill you have a lot of
skill
i've seen your pottery so you're really
good at pottery i've seen your pottery
on social media
so when did you start doing that thank
you um this is
yeah that those are some of my faces um
yeah this is a vase i've made as well
that's so cool i uh i started doing it
again
about two and a half years ago i guess
my wife lauren
um is a very talented uh incredible
woman and and she's always done she's
done pottery since high school basically
and she
always implored me to try it and um she
said
she thought i would like it um and we
finally took a lesson
um and we i i i loved it i really took
to it and and we loved doing it together
it was a really fun
um activity for us to to to do uh with
one another
um and uh yeah and it's uh it's been
great i love it thank god
uh because yeah i mean who who knows how
long they'll let me make movies
you have another trade another well i
have to ask you this
um you're both you said it's an activity
i'll do together please tell me at some
point
you've put on unchained melody and
totally relived the ghost moment
we actually we we've there are times
never that deliberately we should we
should do it just so when we're asked
that question we could be like yes we
we do it all we are sexy people
that mug you're drinking from right now
was made with me
shirtless behind lauren as we um
well here's an idea if unchained melody
doesn't do the trick you can always put
on a moment like this i seem to be an
inspiration for you
so you are you're you're my muse seth's
new book yearbook is out
now um what's it about um it's a
collection of uh
stories that i hope are funny uh for
people that's that's mostly it um true
stories
uh from my life there's kind of essays i
guess uh
on on subjects as well that uh not so
strictly kind of
narrative chapters but um yeah and it's
mostly just
it it's pure goal is to be funny and
entertaining and then i'm using my own
personal experiences to try to write uh
yeah pieces that people just
laugh at and enjoy you know all right
will you talk about meeting some of your
heroes so is it true that bob dylan
almost gave you a harmonica and how does
almost
happen yeah i was at the grammys once uh
years ago only once and the grammys is a
crazy award show compared to movie award
shows and musicians
lead very incredible lives
completely inflated if they want to be
and as i'm sure you've
you've seen firsthand on many occasions
if you're a musician you can make it
that you don't interact with one human
being you don't want to which is like
pretty crazy i think and
uh but anyway i was at the grabbies um
and uh bob dylan was there and he
performed and i actually stole a drink
from his dressing room
um but i personally didn't see him um
but
months a few months later i was at a
party and a guy i know came up to me and
he told me
um you were at the grammys this year and
i said yes and he goes i was there too
with a friend of mine who actually looks
very much like you and while we were at
the grammys a security guard
came up to him and handed him a
harmonica
and said that bob dylan is a big fan of
yours on howard stern and wanted you to
have this
um and i was like well can i have the
harmonica and
um the guy was like no my friend has
kept the harmonica
so and i don't know who this person is i
don't know their name
i honestly don't even remember the
friend who is the mutual person at this
point but if you are watching this and
have the harmonic please just give me
the harmonica
i'll maybe they're a musician and they
don't like talking to people says so
you're never going to see them exactly
maybe they're all completely insulated
from society and we'll never see this
in any way they perform
you need to go to a country award show
because i did grow up with pop award
shows in this industry that is probably
very different country award shows are
very different everyone's door is open
they actually share dressing rooms it's
a different experience
well you and your writing partner evan
goldberg wrote super bad
um was that scene with the beer and the
laundry detergent bottles
from real life um it was uh
again another story uh i referenced in
yearbook is uh
yeah we uh we we noticed when we were
around maybe 16 that
um a lot of bars stored kegs behind
the bar um and so
one night and i don't recommend anyone
do this and i am uh
confessing to a crime right now we went
out and
stole uh a keg from behind
a restaurant basically um not knowing
that you needed like a pump
uh to operate a keg we knew nothing we
were children um
and we noticed there's like a little
pressure ball that kind of keeps the
beer in so we knocked it out with a
hammer
and then beard just kind of poured out
of it and we didn't know what to do so
we just kind of filled my mother had a
lot of tupperware parties
my parents were kind of kept they didn't
throw anything away we had a lot of
empty yogurt containers
um detergent containers things like that
so we kind of just filled up everything
we could
with beer and also we couldn't hide a
keg anywhere so we had to get rid of it
so
we had to empty the keg into tupperware
and things like that
um and then we drank uh lukewarm beer
that had been hidden under our beds
in tupperware and yogurt containers and
detergent bottles
um for the next several weeks um
unrefrigerated just sitting in these
plastic tubs
and the fact that we're still alive is i
guess a testament to the immune system
oh my god it's amazing you are destined
to be creative i'm gonna leave it at
that
um so have your parents read the book i
mean speaking of illegal
did they read it and go what the hell
yes um my mother read the book uh
and specifically was like why do you
tell so many stories about doing drugs
that was her
biggest note and concern um
and truthfully it made me write a whole
part of the book where i talk about why
i tell so many stories about doing drugs
because it really made me think why do i
do this but i don't think she meant it
so literally i think she was more like
why do you do this
but it made me think really why do i do
this
so hopefully the book answers that
question to some degree
as well and maybe a therapist okay
so wait your mom tweets a lot as well um
oh i like your cup by the way that's a
cute little mug thank you lauren
lauren made this did you make oh my gosh
y'all are talented
um do you all sell them do you have like
a place where people can buy them
no maybe one day i'm just saying start
an etsy page lauren i'd buy them
um so wait did you see your mama post
this because this is awesome
um i'm not sure if you can see it um
it's about the orgasms in bridgerton
yes so when bridgette they always you
know yeah
yes my mother i don't know what to tell
you
she this is the lens through which
you've used these shows i
i i don't watch bridgerton that doesn't
well i don't know if that makes me want
to watch it more or less if i'm being
totally
honest it's not something i want to talk
to my mother about ever so
it's probably better i don't watch that
show just to avoid having that
conversation i'm just saying well
you should tell lauren to watch it and
tell her she
oh she devoured that she she watched it
in one weekend
yes you tell her that library scene
yeah yep all right i'm very disappointed
that guy's not returning for a seat
that's been a big
big topic of conversation in our
household i know
i know it is such a great show though
i'm excited to watch it again want more
fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure